你现在就要开始做这个准备，
另一方面呢，
对老人啊，
公公婆婆量力而行，
什么叫量力而行啊，
公公婆婆去医院啊什么的，
你就说没钱，
你别说太善良了，
太心软了，
公婆婆去医院你就垫钱，
没钱直接打电话给他儿子，
他儿子有钱治就治，
她儿子没有钱治的话，
你也没有法律上的义务，
别到时候把你的钱都给公公婆婆治病了，
你和你的女儿没钱吃饭啊，
我先把预防针打在这里，
怎么保护我的权利，
应该怎么跟我对象相处？
我们结婚14年，
有一个女宝宝，
然后7岁，
我们开始是一生了娃，
之后就是把娃放在家里，
奶奶带了几年了，
我就回来在家带娃了，
现在他自己，
我们异地两年了吧，
这其中好像发生了一点变化，
他回来我们就是跟朋友一样，
也没有什么亲密关系，
在家工作不是有点忙嘛，
我要他回来，
我跟他说，
早上他说他还没睡醒，
他说等有空再说，
然后他可能就想好了要怎么对付我，
晚上他就打电话回来，
他就各种理由各种推辞，
反正他就各种理由推脱，
不想回来，
我就是感觉他外面有人了，
但是我没有证据，
那你现在想要问我的问题是什么呢？
我想要问他，
他是不是外面就是。
是可能就是个人的，
如果他是一个健康的，
他那方面的需要是属于正常的，
这样一个男性的话，
那几乎可以说是90%以上的概率是外面有人了，
因为他本来就跟你分居，
以我对于男性的了解，
他回来他不可能不碰你，
因为他解决这个需求，
如果说他跟你分居了，
他回来他都跟你客客气气的，
他不碰你的话，
就是排除说他自己身体出现状况啊，
确实是啊，
那方面出现状况的话，
排除这个因素了之后，
那么大概率想是外面有人了，
还有就是他挣己的钱他也不给我，
他还想要钱，
妈耶，
让你留在家里，
又照顾孩子又照顾老人，
他也没有挣到什么钱，
也不给家里钱，
还问你要钱，
是这个意思哈，
对，
他的工资应该有8000~1万，
这样，
妈耶，
这种男的要他干啥呀，
然后我就想让他回来嘛，
反正他就各种理由不回来，
但是我又不想跟他分，
主要是想用他的资源嘛，
那资源能给你创造价值嘛，
就是能，
所以我才那我劝你几句啊，
第一，
钱要做适当的安排，
不要放在你的名下，
因为他那头你找不到他的证据，
找不到他的财产线索，
他到时候还想分你的钱，
分开这件事情呢，
未必是我不想分开就不分开，
也有可能他到时候想分开。
是吧，
他帮上富婆了，
他想跟我分开也有这种可能，
所以我不能让他想跟我分开的时候还分我的钱，
就是你现在就要开始做这个准备。
另一方面呢，
对老人啊，
公公婆婆量力而行，
什么叫量力而行啊，
公公婆婆去医院啊什么的，
你就说没钱，
你别说太善良了，
太心软了，
公公婆去医院你就垫钱，
没钱直接打电话给他儿子，
他儿子有钱治就治，
他儿子没有钱治的话，
你也没有法律上的义务，
别到时候把你的钱都给公公婆婆治病了，
你和你的女儿没钱吃饭啊，
我先把预防针打在这里，
我这播间有多少女的，
就是说很善良，
哎呦，
他觉得公公婆婆人不错啊，
公婆婆治病了，
住院了，
她马上就去出钱了，
去出力了啊，
千万别，
你没有那么大的能量，
没有那么大的本事啊，
千万别啊，
嗯，
我就给个三万五百这样子就是一点心意多的，
我也不管，
我就这样子，
反正我先把预防针打到这里，
真到有一天说哎呀住院了，
要十万块钱押金的时候，
你脑子里面第一时间想起我今天说的这个话啊，
给他儿子出钱，
他儿子愿意出钱，
出钱，
他儿子不愿意出钱的话，
是他的命，
我跟他说你这个家里都不要了，
有什么原因？
我说除了外面有那啥，
他说你随便去查，
那你还有什么问题想问我呀，
要不要跟他签一个伦你财产协议，
他有什么财产呀，
疫情名下的就是有一套房，
之前也因为就是这些事情闹。
说了一下，
然后我就说要把房子过户给女儿，
然后她不愿意，
我说行，
不愿意那就加名字，
然后现在吃占份额开始占30，
我和我女儿占了70%的份额，
那就挺好的了呀，
那个车也不值钱，
就几万块钱，
但是我的名下的我现在多少存款他不知道，
他也不问我，
我也不问他有多少钱，
他等天就说他没钱，
所以我说你名下的钱你要早做打算，
早做安排，
我现在不是工作很忙，
忙碌不过来嘛。
还有一个点，
我想请假一下，
我可他说要安排他姐来，
他姐是分手了，
现在也没什么好工作，
就是生活的也比较困难，
他说要让他姐来帮我工作，
你觉得我应该让他看这个事儿呢？
得看他姐本人怎么样，
如果他姐本人是属于那种本分踏是工作，
拿钱感恩这样的人的话，
其实未尝不可，
但是我跟你说啊，
通常情况下，
这种亲戚关系是不好相处的。
首先第一点，
你老公这个人，
她那么自私，
她不光是自私，
她都烂人一个是吧，
自己的女儿自己不养，
在外面花天酒地，
一个月挣18000块钱，
也不给家里钱，
还得问你要钱，
就这么烂人一个，
为什么要成他的情，
为什么给他面子？
除非你告诉我，
你跟这个大姑姐本来就相处挺好，
这个大姑姐这个人很他。
能干另外一回事儿，
但是说因为你老公说让他姐来，
你就让他来，
你为什么要给他这个面子，
我没有让他来，
我说你不愿意回来干，
你就不要管，
我说我自己来安排，
我自己干，
我不想让他姐来，
然后我也不想让他知道我到底有多少的收入，
对这个点非常好啊，
算你有点心眼子，
因为我也关注你挺久了，
也都是跟同学一起学的，
那我这边忙不过来的话，
我可以让我娘家的人来帮忙啊，
我觉得这事儿啊，
宁可就是做生意，
这个事儿，
就宁可叫什么白纸黑字，
宁可你干多少活，
我给你多少钱，
别想什么帮忙不帮忙的事儿，
就是这样说的，
我就是给工资嘛，
一个月给你多少钱，
六千五千之类的，
那你自己招个人不香吗？
自己招个人的话，
让干啥干啥是吧，
大家公事公办，
你要娘家找个人来的话，
那又是亲戚又是人情，
人家孩子生病了，
请假回去一个星期，
你能怎么地，
人家老人出什么问题了，
那是我亲哥也也没有亲婚，
我知道啊，
就有的人他处的很好，
比如说那个彩虹夫妇，
他就处的很好，
他能把全家人都团结在他的身边，
大家一起发财，
一起做项目，
但是呢，
也有人做的不好，
就算跟亲哥在一起做的话，
那也是矛盾很深的，
因为大家都觉得干工作嘛，
如果你是老板，
你花5000块钱请一个人，
你花6000块。
安请一个人，
你让他干啥是啥，
那如果是你亲哥的话，
他干着干着时间长了就觉得是他的功劳了，
就是说请那人比较好，
那我就问你一句，
你看龙飞会请自己的亲哥来当助理吗？
我也想过这个问题啊，
因为你是老板，
你知道吧，
你说如果说是什么晚辈，
可能还好一点，
你让他干这个干那个，
一个长辈你让他干这个干那个，
他是你哥，
你让他干这个干那个，
你自己琢磨一下，
这关系怎么处啊，
相比下来的话，
跟他姐和我哥这两个选择，
那哪一个比较好，
我自己干好，
其实我也这样想过，
我大不了我就自己干，
能干多少干多少。
刚才说财产那个问题，
我要不要跟他签那个婚内财产本来现在就已经是按份共有了，
你和孩子占70%，
他占30%，
你说想跟他签协议的目的是什么？
他那30%都让给你是么？
那你觉得他能答应吗？
主要是我想，
就是我赚的钱我不想给他，
他要是愿意签的话，
你可以签呀，
就是我们实行夫妻分别财产制，
各自赚的钱归各自所有，
各自名下债务各自偿还，
没有共同的债务，
如果他愿意的话可以签，
他好像有一点债务，
他的某宝上有两三个W的债务，
他要是不愿意的话，
那也没办法，
那你就只能自己说，
早做打算了，
给孩子开个账户，
你拿着那个卡，
你拿着密。
把钱存到孩子的头上去，
比如说存到孩子在他这个事上共同财产吗？
一般情况下就是两口子闹离婚的时候，
很少会牵扯孩子的婚，
也可以给孩子买那个教育基金啊，
给孩子买一些那个增额终身寿险呢，
都可以啊，
待育基金的话，
他是怎么买的，
那个能跟吗？
啊，
那这个东西你得问那些专业的人啊，
因为我不是这方面专业的，
我不具备这个推荐的资格，
我要是推荐的话是违法的，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
我真的很佩服彩虹哦，
彩虹他真的是把所有基本上能帮的所有的亲戚都围绕在他自己的身边啊，
都跟着他挣钱，
我真的很佩服他，
因为我做不到，
我这性格有点独断专行，
说一不二，
你别以为说龙飞翔好像是平时在直播间看上去挺好说话一个人，
但现实生活中工作起来不是那么回事儿，
工作起来就是这货，
这个品，
我要说我用着不舒服，
你说破天了我也不会上你这个品，
就算你给坑位费，
就算你佣金你拉到50%，
我说不上就不上，
我不爱用就是不爱用，
不好用就是不好用，
对我没有作用就是没有作用，
那你说要是跟亲戚一起啊，
做工作啊什么的，
那到时候他在假设啊，
我哥跟我一起工作，
好商家请我哥吃个饭，
按个脚唱歌，
想要来我这上这个群，
那不就得罪人了吗？
那不就折他面子了吗？
那不就让他。
要脸了吗？
那我要是不上这个题，
那你说关系怎么处关系怎么说我的？
你们记得点赞关注哦。